we need to think carefully about the
priorities we need to be rigorous and at
the same time we also need to look for
the investment to achieve better growth
throughout Europe we all know that we
need to boost investment and demand and
I think that the budget is a very good
investment vehicle so we believe that
the Commission proposal needs to be cut
by about 100 million we're all engaged
in a policy of budgetary consolidation
we have to defend that before national
parliaments and it must be continued at
European level to the fundamental truth
we have to face up to is the member
states are making considerable financial
efforts to support Europe and at the
same time to undertake very demanding
consolidation efforts of their own and
European public spending simply cannot
be exempt there is a clear link between
national austerity and the European
budget we have a lot of constraints on
our national budgets if we now start
increasing the European budget we are
not going to be very popular at home we
cannot just look at priorities but we
also have to take into account what
countries are prepared to spend given
the fact that this current financial
crisis requires critical reflection all
of us are national and European budgets
Ireland sees the Commission's proposal
as a good basis for the work ahead and
what's more within the framework we have
noted that a heading to sustainable
growth and natural resources is the only
element showing restraint if we want to
be credible if we're going to talk about
relaunching growth and employment we
need a European budget that is a fairly
robust and there
we'll make the necessary investments I
would like to emphasize in need to
consolidate the creation policy and the
Common Agricultural Policy we believe
that the resources made available have
to make it possible for us to rise to
the various challenges that face the
European Union today malt is not
comfortable with the elements of
taxation contained in the Commission's
proposal and we are particularly
skeptical of the Commission's insistence
on introducing a financial transactions
tax into the own resources system for
many countries cohesion policy is an
investment in times of austerity and
probably as our own experience has shown
the only investment in gross a political
quiz ow stop police Lucien to the Veneti
policy in our view is a clearly one of
our priorities in fact it would be
illogical and indeed schizophrenia occur
for us today to be talking about cuts in
an instrument that it's promotes growth
and employment the brass mukunda fighter
stems approach hora de novo schloss
orange various mission ENT and bail
regarding the Common Agricultural Policy
we cannot afford to continue spending
around forty percent of the total body
don actions which I'm sorry to say it
have only little effect on growth and
employment we support the overall size
of the you budget as proposed by the
college Commission which is already
limited and clearly reflects
consolidation measures taken by member
states we welcome the fact that this is
a budget based on solidarity with the
member states and them for the poorest
member states and regions and able to
sue meet together the major challenges
facing us we also see that the
Commission recognizes the need for
consolidation of public expenditure at
European level the prime question of our
work should not be how much should we
spend but foremost what should we spend
for in order to foster growth and jobs
nudism we must head towards agriculture
which is sustainable productive and
competitive
tiffin that that must be an essential
pillar of European policies and we
should not consider it to be a policy
which cannot produce jobs what we
Slovakia want is a Europe which is
consolidated which is cohesive and which
is competitive and we believe that the
Commission has done a good job in
balancing the finances for the policies
that we need the man prayer till the
Czech Republic is a strong cohesion
policy they will primarily focus on the
development and convergence of the less
developed regions in member states
another enhancement I was a
competitiveness rookie lacroix she owned
a hacer austere eda austerities all very
good on a national level but we don't
need austerity at an EU level I think
the money that we spend it in EU level
does have a multiplier effect it does
provide a value-added humble or an ideal
a reasonable balance must be found
between the national austerity
challenges and the investment needs for
the EU policies at this stage of
negotiations on the mff we could agree
with the Commission's proposal for the
overall amount of the multi-annual
financial framework stressing the need
to guarantee the level of funding for
education policy mean is strongly
interested in ensuring proper financing
for the cohesion policy and for the
Common Agricultural Policy we believe
that our traditional policies such as
c.a.p and cohesion policy must be
preserved as a strong and integrated
community policies they make three you
stronger and more united in a time of
crisis when a growing number of our
citizens question the success and the
efficiency of the European project want
to be like Germany the Netherlands UK
and others our opinion is that the
Commission proposal is about 100 billion
euros too high and that consequently all
headings must make a contribution to a
reduction one of the main prey
ready for Cyprus is cohesion policy we
believe in this policy we consider it an
expression of solidarity and of the
European spirit this debate has shown
that there will be no easy way to solve
the issue of the mff if anyone had
thought in advance that we would have
the solution today they would be
disappointed